abuse of office that was one of the
charges rejected in the Senate
impeachment trial but the Democrats
should have filed the article against
themselves because they're the ones who
were guilty of abusing their office and
the public's trust the president has
been hunted hounded defamed and
investigated since the day he announced
his run for the White House Democrats
the deep state and the media all
conspired together to undermine his
presidency by relentlessly impugning his
character he was a Russian stood
remember that or Putin was blackmailing
him he was running a criminal enterprise
it was all false all of it they even
went after its family even the first
lady most rugged pair of construction
stilettos so it's okay for Donal from
jr. and Eric Trump to do business all
over the world it's ok I think that the
bullseye and the family right now it's
on Jared Kushner they really are my
family they make us are they nam are
they dead inside they paid off I mean
what's their deal yes yes and yes but I
yes a fan yes then they impeached him
and they tried to remove him from office
using a fake whistleblower who still
hasn't had the guts to show his face
there was no impeachable conduct there
were no crimes
there was never intent to commit any and
yet Adam Schiff wanted to inflict
maximum pain on this president ten
months before the next election and now
this it gets me even after the
president's acquittal the Democrats are
hinting at more impeachments it's all
they know how to do and they even do
that badly what was the president
expected to do after all this thank them
you think he's going to try to heal the
country not a chance
it was mean-spirited it was poisonous it
was spiteful unscripted
vindictive isn't somebody in deep
psychological distress right now if this
was a thoughtful person he would have
said look I've been acquitted it's
really not now time to heal the nation
but he can't seem to do that what did
they want a bouquet of roses sent to
Capitol the people who speculated about
sending him to jail after he left office
or the people who threatened to have his
lawyers disbarred those people whose
phony investigations bankrupted good
people Donald Trump left a really
comfortable life to run in hopes of
making America a richer and more
powerful country and he has the
Democrats only response was to plot and
connive and conspire against him
regardless of the facts regardless of
the damage that it would do to our
country I was thinking about this today
as I was sitting in that room watching
him speak fiery as ever thanking people
and also calling out all the right
people I thought to myself you know it
didn't have to be this way the Democrats
could have tried to understand Trump
voters the people that Hillary called
deplorable they might have even tried to
appeal to them they could have moved
expeditiously the Democrats to pass
legislation that they actually agreed
with like the u.s. MCA instead of
sitting on it for a year they could have
passed an infrastructure bill instead
they just pulled stupid stunts
Democratic leaders walked out of a White
House meeting just a short time ago
after what Nancy Pelosi described as a
presidential meltdown Speaker Nancy
Pelosi left the meeting after some
name-calling accusing the president of
having a quote meltdown over Syria see
how it's all in sync Democrats wouldn't
even confirm mid-level political
appointees of Donald Trump and of course
they went scorched earth on Kavanagh
their surrogates filed lawsuits against
common-sense immigration rules and
enforcement and runaway judges issued
nationwide injunctions that made our
country less safe and tied the hands of
law enforcement
so Trump was right after all this he
needed to blow off a little steam today
Adam Schiff is a vicious horrible person
Nancy Pelosi is a horrible person
and if I didn't fire James Comey we
would have never found this stuff
because when I fired that sleazebag all
hell broke out it was evil it was
corrupt it was dirty cops
it was leakers and liars it was all
these people have done stone cold crazy
but I beaten them all my life
and I'll beat him again if I have to he
torched him
it got hot in there but he's exactly
right and excuse me if I don't give a
fire extinguisher to the people who've
been throwing flames at the president
since inauguration day when they say
that oh we need more civility in
politics what they really mean is they
want total control where they call the
shots you sit down you shut up and you
just keep shoveling taxes to Washington
to pay for programs by the way they
don't work and that you never supported
the Democrats are a party spent they're
a party at war with itself one that even
in defeat has grown corrupt and decadent
its establishment can't even count votes
in Iowa or didn't wanna count they're
either incompetent or the ultimate
election meddlers the Democrats love
things during the bush years though
didn't they when Republicans mostly
played nice when ever the Democrat
critics hit them really hard and how did
that all work out for the GOP in the end
the president has demonstrated that at
the same time of all this stuff going on
all the attacks but he can and will work
with pretty much anyone and he has he's
done this with incredibly smart and even
powerful leaders who have a lot of scary
weapons he's worked with people like
President Xi of China but Nancy Pelosi
sits on her hands she smirks she rips up
papers she storms out of rooms she
points and she pulls other stunts she
doesn't want to work with him what does
she actually accomplished
other than in bolding the radicals in
her own party oh and by the way do not
believe for a second that this divisive
'no sand vitriol is only because of
Trump and the Trump era he caused it all
they relentlessly made fun of george w
bush for being a dumb jock and they
called him a war monger they even
ridiculed John McCain for marrying a
rich wife who had eight houses they
accused Mitt Romney of being a vulture
capitalist and mean two dogs
they even trashed Sarah Palin's
special-needs child today is Ronald
Reagan's birthday my old boss
they said he was just a stupid actor who
slept in the afternoons these are
vicious people they stick together
historically I'm not talking now they
stick together like glue again he's
right then they do but when the
Democrats threw down the gauntlet and
tried to beat us an open combat this
time around they were met by an actual
fighter America elected a brawler like
Trump and rejected a baller like mitt
and that's the angle